There is a narration that I want to
share
with my brothers, my sisters
with respect to
the exaltation of knowledge
and how we treat knowledge
and how we mistreat knowledge.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us
He says
[Silence]
In this verse
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
[Arabic recitation]
and
the Muslimin, anyone who reads these
verses, hears these verses,
how exactly we are to treat knowledge
in order that we can be treated with
knowledge.
He says, "Subhana wa ta'ala, oh you who
have believed, if you are told to make
room in your gathering, then make room.
And if you are told to rise, then rise."
If you're told to make room, meaning
the reason that this verse was revealed
is that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would be sitting and
people would be mustered around him.
Nobody wants to lose their place.
Everyone wants to be in the front. They
want to be close. They want to hear. So,
this shows us first of all
how the companions radiyallahu anhu
behaved towards knowledge. Whenever they
had
an instance or an opportunity
to
sit and listen to knowledge, they didn't
spread out and go to the end of the
masjid and sit down and act you
know, it's just go ahead, talk,
entertain me, you know. This is not how
they behaved.
They would muster around the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and later the
other companions who would teach.
And they would come close.
But they were a little bit too much in
that.
And so, Allah says, "If you are told to
make room in your gathering, then make
room."
Make room in your gathering.
Told by who?
By the teacher.
In this verse, the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam or anyone who fills that
position of teaching. Make room. Someone
comes in, make room for him. He sits
down. You take
You take that direction. He says, "And
if you are told to rise, then rise."
They would come to the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. He would
invite them to eat. He would invite them
into his place.
And they would want to linger. They
would eat and then they would want to
hang out. They would want to sit and
talk and
And so the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam found it difficult to
articulate
his discontentment with that. He's got
things to do. He needs to
have his own time. He needs to have his
own
And so he would indicate, but his
indications weren't being picked up on.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala had to
spell it out for him in the Quran
subhanahu wa ta'ala in a number of
verses. But one of the commandments was,
"And if you are told to rise,
then rise." Meaning
leave. Yani infadhu. Insarifoo.
All right? Then Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said,
"Allah will raise
those believers amongst you and those
who were given knowledge specifically."
So Allah will raise all believers
generally, but those who are given
knowledge, he will raise them
specifically
and much higher than the rest.
And
we notice here the correlation between
manners, etiquette, and knowledge,
right? There's an etiquette. You know,
the people of knowledge, they they speak
a particular language, a particular
etiquette. Any field, any any human
beings, is one of the things that sets
the human being aside from all other
creatures. We have an etiquette, right?
We have an etiquette when we go to eat.
We have an etiquette when we, , you
know, mechanics have an etiquette. They
have terminologies. They have etiquette.
They have things they do, things they
don't do, things they view to be
offensive, and things that they view to
be necessary, right?
And
in every other field.
Well, in order to access knowledge from
the people of knowledge, the scholars of
Islam and their students, those people
who are the heirs of Muhammad,
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. This is not
just every other person. This is an
heir of prophethood.
The people of knowledge are an heir to
prophethood. They inherited from him.
[Arabic recitation]
into the marketplace one day,
and he announced in the marketplace,
"You all are here in the market.
Meanwhile, the prophet's inheritance is
being distributed in the masjid."
They, of course, thought that what he
meant
was,
you know, his shoes, his clothes, his
things that he had.
And so, people rushed to the masjid and
found who there? They found the
companions there teaching.
This is what the prophets left behind.
And how you behave, even the way that
you
sit, the way that you
This all has to do with how much
knowledge you will be allotted by Allah
and by the the gatekeepers of knowledge.
The men and the women that keep that
knowledge. You don't have an inherent
right to it. You have earn it.
And there's a way to access it. You have
to speak their language and you have to
learn their language. A lot of times you
hear
"Oh, you know, it's just not engaging
enough. I need Already? Someone who has
this I idea of we need to think of new
and inventive ways to make people want
to learn about the Quran and the Sunnah.
We need to reinvent the wheel. People
are different and so we need to we need
to figure out a way to incentivize
people. Is the hellfire not a good
enough incentive?
What about paradise? Is that a good
incentive?
It's not an issue of
if I go to the masjid and if I learn,
I'm doing someone a favor. I You know,
I'm going above and beyond. You are
barely servicing your own salvation.
This is not an issue of
you know,
a person can turn away from Islam
and that's their choice and Islam loses.
No. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says
that
lan tador Allah shayan.
He said to the companions, "If you all
turn away
and leave Islam, all of you, you will
not harm Allah. You will not harm Islam
in the least.
They will not be harmed by that. We need
Islam.
Islam doesn't need us.
We need Allah. He is a summit.
A summit does not need us. That is the
dynamic here.
And so, how we accept this knowledge,
whether
or not anyone sees us or not, Allah is
watching us. So, I'll share this
narration here. In Sahih al-Bukhari in
the book of knowledge,
a group of three men arrived in Medina.
Now, these men had arrived in Medina for
what purpose?
They made hijrah. They came to Medina to
see the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam.
And
as they arrived, they walked into the
masjid and they found that he was
sitting
and the companions were around him.
And so, each of these three men did
something different than the other.
One of them turned around and left.
The other one
sat behind the circle.
They didn't sit how we sit when we
try to learn. They didn't sit in the
rows over there and stare at the wall
while the person teaching is talking to
the wall over here.
Could you imagine if if I did that?
Would you consider that rude?
Seriously. If I sat and looked at this
wall right now and gave you this talk
right here, would you would you be
offended?
Or if I just stared off into the
distance this. I I acted like
there's no one here right now.
Or I stared over here in the middle and
I left everyone and make no eye contact
with anyone, speak as if no one is here.
Wouldn't you be offended by that?
It's offensive, isn't it?
The companions radi Allah anhu would
gather around. They would sit around.
They would face the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam. They would face their
teachers, Ubayy ibn Ka'b, Abdullah ibn
Mas'ud, Abdullah ibn Umar. They would
face them.
They would show that respect in order to
receive. The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam says
that one of the men left.
The other one came in
and found the circle around the prophet
alaihi wasallam was kind of
was kind of full, so he didn't want to
to disturb
the circle, right? So, the prophet is
speaking, he's going to come in and then
say, "Hey, could you move a little bit?"
That dis- that is a disruption. He
didn't want to disrupt. He wanted to be
a fly on the wall and hear what the
prophet
alaihi wasallam is saying, not for the
prophet's sake. He wasn't doing him a
favor. He was doing his own soul a
favor.
I am lost in the darknesses of this
world. I am in desperate need of
cleansing.
Right? And so, he was too shy to make
that disturbance. So, he sat behind the
general group.
And the third,
he was a little bit more ambitious.
And so, he went in to sit and without
having to say anything, naturally, the
companions
made room and he sat down. Why? Because
this verse had already been revealed at
that time. The verse that we started
with and they had already understood to
be vigilant of any other person coming
to make room for them to sit.
And so, after he was completed, after he
finished,
let's take a stop there. Could you
imagine if the companions and the
prophet
alaihi wasallam were in our time?
Could you imagine them being on the
phone on their phones as he's speaking?
what about Abu Bakr? What about Ibn
Mas'ud? What about all the way to
scholars today?
What's the difference? Time?
Or, you know, that's something for the
prophet, but nobody These are the heirs
of the prophets.
And they have the same knowledge that is
being spoken.
And so, after he was finished, he said,
"Shall I not inform you of
what Allah's response was to those three
men that just approached?"
And so, they said, "Bala ya Rasul
Allah."
He said, "The first one, he turned away,
and Allah in turn turned away from him."
Imagine that.
The poor soul doesn't even know that
that happened.
And because he left, that word of, "Hey,
did you know that Allah turned away from
you when you turned away from Allah's
words and his messenger?" He doesn't
even know that happened.
Do you think he found out later? Maybe,
maybe not. We don't know. Maybe even he
doesn't know.
But he said, "He turned away,
and so Allah turned away from him."
And as for the second,
he was shy before Allah, meaning he
didn't want to interrupt
the revelation of Allah. And so, Allah
was in turn
shy with him.
He said, "And as for the third,
as for the third, he came
to seek sanctuary with Allah, and Allah
granted him that sanctuary.
All of this happened, not one of them
said a word.
And why is it Allah is
having these interactions with them?
What was What does that mean, Allah?
Were they headed towards Allah? Was it
the Quran being recited in this
particular instance? No, maybe verses
were being studied, the words of the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam. But,
the words of Allah, the words of the
prophet, and the understanding of those
words is of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so, how you treat that knowledge is
how you will be treated by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this is a mistake that a lot of
people don't even recognize.
For instance, if I were to say
in a conversation, just you and I, two
people, I say, "You know, as Allah said,
wal asr,
innal insana lafi khusr, nine people out
of 10 will not let you finish that
without saying it with you or telling
you, "I know. I already know. I know."
This is not how a person listens
to the Quran.
As soon as someone says,
"Allah said, the prophet said,"
immediately there is only one person
speaking, we listen.
And when you show that respect, that
exaltation
to Allah's words, to the prophet's
words, to the people of knowledge, that
exaltation now starts to raise you. Now
you are speaking the the not this the
language of the people of knowledge.
This is the first step in learning.
But, ignorance, unfortunately, is a a
silent killer. It's very similar to a
cancer.
Because a lot of the time ignorance is
painless for the most part. A person
will not recognize how ignorant they are
or how much they need knowledge until
they learn it.
It's if you were in a toxic
environment, physically toxic,
making your body sick, you
it's just enough to make you sick but
not enough to make you bedridden.
You wouldn't even recognize
just how toxic it was until you what?
Until you leave that environment.
If we all lived in the dark all the
time, we would never know what the light
has to offer until we experience it.